j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public vous le savez on cherche le plus
souvent possible à le décaler
volontairement de l'actualité du jour
pour tenter ce soir de comprendre tiens
comment un pays qui se rêvait comme un
petit paradis est devenu en 5 années à
peine une plaque tournante du
narcotrafic où les chefs de gang font la
loi ce pays vous le savez c'est
l'Équateur le Président il a décrété un
couvre-feu c'était le 8 janvier dernier
voyage au pays de la peur avec Mathias
Arz depuis bientôt 6 mois l'équateur est
plongé dans une crise sans précédent
véritable plaque tournante de la drogue
en Amérique latine est tournée vers le
monde le pays est au prise avec la
violence des cartels en août dernier
Fernando via viiceno candidat antimafia
à l'élection présidentielle est
assassiné pendant la campagne le jour de
son meurtre il annonçait vouloir en
finir avec les
narcotrafiquants camarade le choix se
fera entre la mafia et la patrie soit
les mafieux triomphent et reviennent
soit le bon peuple les démocrates les
gens courageux gagneront la bataille et
la patrie en sortira
vainqueur selon Pascal Drou spécialiste
de l'Amérique latine et des relations
internationales la situation n'est pas
nouvelle dans le continent ce sont les
logiques de de des conflits internes qui
pouvait y avoir en Amérique latine dans
les années 80 où les cibles sont
précises elles sont symboliques on
frappe des candidats aux élection
présidentielle on menace le chef de
l'État on tue des juges on on cherche à
impressionner
et menacer les journalistes tous les
vecteurs d'influence de la société c'est
ça un conflit interne et c'est ce que
vit aujourd'hui l'équateur depuis
l'élection de Daniel Noboa candidat
d'une droite dure et prenant la fermeté
face aux violences le pays déclare la
guerre au gang criminel début janvier un
groupe d'hommes armé et cagoulet fait
irruption sur le plateau de la
télévision publique prenant en otage des
journalistes le Président déclare alors
l'état
d'urgence je viens de signer le décret
sur l'état d'urgence pour que les forces
armées et tout le soutien politique et
juridique dans leur action nous ne
négocierons pas avec les terroristes et
nous ne nous reposerons pas tant que
nous n'aurons pas rendu la paix à tous
les
Équatoriens déploiement de forces armées
dans les lieux publics opération de
maintien de l'ordre dans les prisons et
trac de l'ennemi public numéro 1 tous
les moyens sont bons pour ramener le
calme pour la population locale avec une
population notamment dans la capitale
qui euh attend beaucoup des mesures
prises par le président Noboa il est
urgent que l'État puisse montrer sa
force et bien évidemment avec sa force
la légitimité d'usage de sa force le
chef de l'État bénéficie donc de 60
jours pour mettre fin à la crise avant
d'ouvrir un chantier plus profond et
poursuivre une paix durable on vous
explique ce cauchemar équatorien avec
Emmanuel Sinardet bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes professeur de
civilisation latinoaméricaine à nent
université Christophe Ventura bonsoir et
bienvenue bonsoir directeur de recherche
à lyis spécialiste de l'Amérique latine
et auteur de ce livre
désoccidentalisation repenser l'ordre du
monde qui est publié aux éditions Agon
thry Noël bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
bonsoir merci historien spécialisé
violence en Amérique latine auteur de la
guerre des cartels publié aux éditions
vendmières et Tam tranui évidemment
éditoraliste politique est resté à mes à
mes côtés peut-être le constat pour
commencer avec quelques chiffres il y a
5 ans l'équateur est était considéré
comme l'un des des plus sûrs d'Amérique
latine et on va le voir avec ce ces
données depuis 2019 le nombre de morts
violent a été multiplié par 7 on est
passé de 6,7 pour 100000 habitants à 45
morts violentes pour 100000 habitants
Emmanuel peut-être pour commencer qui
sont ces victimes sont des forcément des
des membres des cartels de la drogue
c'est des règlements de compte c'est des
habitants des quartiers qui d'un seul
coup se trouvent sous le sous le jou de
des des cartels c'est tous là en même
temps c'est-à-dire que d'abord ça va été
une violence circonscrite aux prisons où
les règlements de compte étaient
particulièrement meurtriés avec parfois
des victimes qui n'avait rien à voir
avec la drogue mais qui était pris entre
deux feux puis la violence a commencé à
s'étendre dans les rues sachant que ces
groupes
transnationaux s'appuient sur des
trafiquants locaux des délinquants
locaux qui font du micro traffic ce qui
a là aussi donné lieu à un très fort
sentiment d'insécurité une montée de la
violence dans la rue dans les quartiers
et puis ces groupes se sont aussi
diversifiés si on peut le dire ainsi
dans leurs activités en s'en prenant aux
commerçants par des extorsions ou euh en
pratiquant ce qu'on appelle des
séquestros Express c'est-à-dire des
enlèvements Express on demande
immédiatement une rançon euh donc peu à
peu une violence circonscrite à des
lieux très précis les prisons et a des
populations très précises et bien envahi
l'espace public et c'est s étendu des
zones frontalières du port de goayquille
à différentes régions qui étaient juste
là extrêmement calm notamment lesandes
et notamment la ville de Kito qui se
croyait relativement épargné jusqu'à
l'assassinat qu'on a vu du candidat
bijabo à Quito en pleine rue après un
meeting donc donc ça c'est le constat en
reste dans le Conat est-ce que cette
montée de la violence elle s'explique
aussi par un affaiblissement un peu
général des des forces de l'ordre en
Équateur oui c'est un des c'est pas le
seul du tout mais c'est un des éléments
qui explique en fait l'accélération de
la dégradation de la situation en
Équateur à partir effectivement des
années 201728 où la courbe de la
criminalité va augmenter à mesure
effectivement que les politiques
publiques en fait de l'État équatorien
qui à l'époque décide de mettre en place
des polies d'ajustement des politiques
de de rigueur B ça va affecter Mo moyens
dans les il y a moins de moyens il a
moins de formation il y a moins
d'équipement on va même à un moment
donné avoir une idée assezrenu de de
fermer littéralement le ministère de de
la justice on va baisser le le budget
des prisons de 30 % à un moment donné
évidemment tout ça a des impacts sur ce
qui est aussi un service public hein
celui de la Sûreté publique et de la
sécurité donc ça a évidemment joué dans
la la le changement du rapport de force
en fait entre les narcotrafiquants les
gangs et cetera et les forces de l'ordre
ouais alors il y a évidemment cette
étape importante dans dans la guerre
entre l'État équatorien et les et les
cartels et c'est ce qui a fait surgir en
tout cas pour nous européens et français
ce pays dans notre actualité c'était le
8 janvier dernier l'évasion de deux
chefs de gang criminels notamment alors
pardon je je ne suis pas hispanophone
rosé adolpo Maas surnommé phito on voit
ça sa photo c'était lors de son
transfert dans une prison de sécurité
Thierry Noël pourquoi c'était pas si
difficile pour lui et pour l'autre chef
de gang de s'échapper de ses prisons
comment ça se passe dans ces
établissements disons que ces derniers
temps c'est je dirais C dernières années
sur le modèle du Mexique he quelque
chose qui se pratique au Mexique mais
aussi ailleurs en Amérique centrale le
les prisons sont devenus des centres de
de concentration en fait des de la
délinquence et de ces gangs et du du
crime organisé qui se disputent
d'ailleurs leur contrôle on a eu ça
donné opportunité de ces tristes
massacres de de plusieurs centaines de
personnes à chaque fois desmeutes entre
gang en prison ce sont des deô pris ils
ont plus ou moins le contrôle de la
prison c'est ça exactement et donc il
est pas forcément très difficile de de
s'en échapper paradoxalement c'est même
souvent un endroit où on va se protéger
alias fito était protégé de la
concurrence et des actions de civau en
prison c'est pour ça qu' pas sor plôt
par qu'on pourrait se poser la question
on choisit de s'en échapper quand il y a
par contre ça devient tendu où il y a
quelque chose à faire ces derniers temps
il y a un certain nombre de de leaders
du gang des choneros Don dont il est
après maintenant le nouveau leader qui
ont été assassiné ou arrêter lui
visiblement a décidé d'en sortir pour
reprendre les choses en main d'accord
alors pour comprendre pour pourquoi ce
pays qui se rêvait d'ailleurs peut-être
en paradis est devenu infernal il faut
regarder une carte de la région
l'équateur qui est niché entre les deux
plus gros producteurs de cocaïne au
monde la Colombie et le Pérou Emmanuel
sininardet il faut peut-être remonter à
l'année 2016 en faire un tout petit peu
d'histoire pour comprendre cet engrenage
là fatal qui s'est qui s'est mis en
place qu'est-ce qui se passe cette
annéel en Colombie alors c'est la
signature des accords de paix qui ont
pour effet de désarmer démilitariser
certains groupe qui vivait du
narcotrafic une partie accepté de
retourner à la vie civile pour le dire
ainsi mais d'autres de façon très
fragmenté et éclaté ont décidé de
poursuivre leurs activités ils ont donc
cherché un nouveau terrain et le pays le
plus proche avec une frontière
extrêmement poreuse et difficile à
contrôler c'est évidemment l'équateur
donc il était assez facile de faire
transiter la cocaïne vers l'équateur de
là ils ont passé d'une série d'accords
avec des gangs locaux et puis cette
route l'équateur
a aussi intéressé d'autres acteurs
globaux transnationaux de la drogue
notamment les cartels mexicains et voilà
des acteurs multiples éclatés qui jouent
à différentes échelles du petit
trafiquant qui fait du MICR trrafique
parce qu'il obtient de la drogue il est
payé en drogue par les grands cartels
euh toutes les échelles se finalement se
superpose dans ce petit pays qui est
l'équateur et qui se retrouve en très
peu de temps l'espace de 4 c'est ça qui
est très étonnant c'est la rapidité de
la la transformation supermarché de la
drogue et la population se sent
véritablement prise en otage ouais
Christophe Ventura c'est c'est c'est
quoi aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est le
premier pays à à envoyer de la drogue
vers vers le monde entier l'équateur
c'est à quel point c'est devenu une
plaque tournante VO alors déjà c'est
devenu le pays le plus dangereux
d'Amérique latine on l'a dit ça c'est le
un bilan de tout cela aujourd'hui
l'équateur son principal marché
d'exportation si je puis dire
figurez-vous c'est l'Europe c'est même
la Belgique puisque l'essentiel de la
drogue qui part d'Équateur en fait va à
enverse en Belgique et de manière
secondaire aussi au Havre et aussi en
Espagne on a retrouvé des des fililières
par là avec l'aide ou le soutien ou le
prolongement bah d'un rangeta calabraise
pour la pour ce qui est de la mafia et
aussi de la mafia albanaise donc ça
c'est pour la partie européenne il faut
que les gens qui nous écoutent sachent
que le premier marché de consommation
mondiale des drogues ce sont les
États-Unis au pluriel le principal
marché mondial de consommation de la
cocaïne c'est l'Europe alors justement
Tam vous vouliez parler de de de
finalement de notre on a un peu défloré
votre votreito mais c'est pas grave
parce que euh on est peut-être en partie
responsable de ce qui se passe en
Équateur et oui est-ce que nous Français
nous Européens sommes responsables de la
guerre des narcos à l'autre bout du
monde c'est la question que je me suis
posée effectivement si on regarde les
flux c'est une évidence hein la cocaïne
produite en Amérique latine n'y reste
pas sa destination c'est le monde et
notamment de plus en plus l'Europe
l'équateur est donc un hub pour la
cocaïne en provenance du P Pérou de la
Colombie d'où est exporté la drogue à
l'internationale direction cette autre
plateforme tournante dont vous avez
parlé le port belge d'enverse première
porte d'entrée de la cocaïne en Europe
et où les saisies de cette drogue ont
atteint des niveaux records écoutez le
ministre belge des Finances qui dresse
un constat sans
appel si l'on considère les chiffres les
saisie de drogue et de cocaïne augmente
à nouveau année après année nous avons
désormais 116 tonnes de cocaïne saisie
dans le port d'enverse cela signifie
bien sûr que nos douaniers font un
excellent travail en saisissant ces
drogues mais cela signifie probablement
aussi qu'il y ait une augmentation du
nombre de drogues qui arrivent en Europe
alors attention aux chiffres à ne pas
extrapoler les chiffres des saisies qui
ne donnent qu'un aperçu partiel du
trafic he par définition mais pour vous
donner une idée 116 tonnes de cocaïne
c'est 5 % de plus que la drogue qui
avait été saisie en 2022 qui était
vraiment déjà une année record et cette
année pour la première fois l'équateur
est devenu devant la Colombie le premier
pays expéditeur de cocane Europe et donc
ça pose la question évidemment de la
consommation de cette cocaïne en Europe
et en France alors une surprise quand
j'ai regardé quelle était la
consommation des jeunes Français les
adolescents ils se droguent de moins en
moins c'est ce qu'on voit notamment avec
le cannabis qui reste toutefois la
première drogue consommée mais ce n'est
pas du tout le cas pour la cocaïne elle
était consommée par moins d'un % des
Français en 2010 1,6 % en 2017 et ça
aurait doublé l'année dernière en 2023
les Français quand considère la cocaïne
comme de moins en moins dangereuse pour
leur santé et en plus il n'est pas du
tout compliqué de s'en procurer elle se
trouve facilement sur internet via les
réseaux sociaux en livraison à domicile
he vous pouvez vous en faire livrer
comme des sushis ou une pizza pas besoin
d'aller sur des points de Deal et est
loin l'image de la drogue des élites à
usage récréatif c'est simple selon le
professeur amine Benyamina président de
la Fédération française d'adictologie
elle concerne aujourd'hui tout le monde
je le cite dans un entretien avec le
Parisien c'est un un étudiant en école
de commerce un jeune employé d'une boîte
de pub des journalistes beaucoup de
soignants aussi des gamins on consomme
de temps en temps et la cocaïne circule
même dans les lycées et on peut ajouter
aujourd'hui aussi la restauration le BTP
les chauffeurs routiers la cocaïne est
de plus en plus présente dans certaines
professions pénibles pour tenir et donc
pour lutter contre ce narcotrafic
équatorien faut aussi agir sur les
consommateurs français européens éid
c'est un marché comme un autre avec un
une offre une demande il faut agir sur
les deux bah sur la demande il y a pas
de solution toute faite il faut agir sur
les addictions faire de la prévention
peut-être même travailler sur les
conditions de travail c'est
multifactoriel avoir conscience que
prendre de la cocaïne c'est alimenter un
trafic ultravolent l'exploitation des
personnes le blanchiment d'argent et
même que c'est un fléo environnemental à
l'autre bout du monde parce que la
culture de la cocaïne est aussi synonyme
de déforestation de contamination bref
culpabiliser les consommateurs ce n'est
pas un ressort bien efficace mais
j'avais quand même envie de le dire sur
ce plateau qu'on est quand même quelque
part dans sa tête que ce droguer ce
n'est pas un simple acte individuel mais
c'est bien participer à un trafic
mondialisé et ben c'est dit et merci Tam
de l'avoir dit euh toujours sur cet
aspect internationale je reste avec vous
Christophe Ventura est-ce qu'il y a une
coopération internationale pour lutter
contre ces trafic d' et donc peut-être
finalement venir en aide à à l'équateur
qui se retrouve de en quelques années au
centre de ce trafic alors ça c'est une
question à la fois centrale et est très
vaste et un peu impuissant fond oui il y
a des coopérations contre la lutte
contre le narcoos et les drogues alors
j'aurais pu poser la question différ
est-ce qu'elle est efficace cette
coopération ben en fait oui et non je
vais avoir une réponse un peu comme ça
oui parce que de fait de nombreux
cartels sont démembrés de fait on
détruit beaucoup on saisit de plus en
plus on détruit on décapite des réseaux
on met des gens en prison et cetera oui
mais en même temps la vérité des prix
c'est que ces 10 dernières années et ça
enfin je rebondis un peu sur ce que vous
disiez C ces 10 dernières années la
consommation la production de la cocaïne
elle a doublé en 10 ans dans le monde
elle s'est donc exportter dans le monde
ça a doublé faut faut entendre ce que ça
veut dire donc c'est énorme ça veut dire
que ça ne marche pas c'est l'idée que on
va baser la lutte contre les drog sur sa
sur la militarisation de cette lutte et
aussi sur une stratégie qui vise à
détruire l'offre en fait ne règle pas le
problème elle le déplace elle le fait
muter elle le fait évoluer elle le
radicalise aussi mais le problème c'est
ce que vous avez dit c'est la
consommation et la demande et comme elle
est elle augmente de manière
exponentielle également dans des régions
nouvelles comme en Asie en Océanie en
Afrique et ben aujourd'hui les
coopérations elles existent de manière
sécuritaire sur le plan sécuritaire mais
du point de vue des politiques public
non ouais Thierry Noël à quel point ces
cartels sont riches aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'on peut répondre à cette question
parce que forcément c'est de l'argent
caché blanchi et cetera et cetera ce
sont des fortunes extraordinaires ce
sont pas forcément eux qui en profitent
le plus uniquement on sait que les
l'époque des grands cartels est révolu
des vraiment très très grandes
structures à l'époque d'un Escobar qui
contrôlait d'un bout à l'autre la chaîne
de production et de distrition des
droges est révolu on a maintenant
beaucoup de petites organisations on a
notamment en décapitant les grandes
organisations on a atomisé le trafic en
multiples petites organisations qui se
disputent le le contrôle de celui-ci et
les bénéfices de celui-ci d'où
d'ailleurs sûrement un excès de violence
un renforcement de la violence il y a
aussi beaucoup d'argent qui doit être
blanchi d'une manière ou d'une autre il
y a des pertes à ce niveau-là c'est
jamais totalement perdu évidemment ça
rentre dans un système financier qui en
profite bien donc oui on a des
organisations criminel qui continue à
faire des fortunes peut-être moins
qu'avant en tout cas qui doivent se le
distribuer et beaucoup d'argent les
sommes d'argent qui se distribu partout
jusqu'à rentrer dans le système légal et
être être blanchi donc légalisé d'une
manière d'une manière ou d'une autre
alors on va parler de la de la de la
réponse de la stratégie que le président
équatorien peut mener dans dans un
instant mais mais avant de la détailler
peut-être ce que ça coûte de de faire la
guerre à ses à ces narco trafiquant en
Équateur parce qu'il a choisi une
réponse voilà on va dire virile je vais
employer ce ce ce terme là est-ce qu'il
est aidé tiens c'est ça le le point
précis de ma question est-ce qu'il y a
une aide internationale pour l'équateur
en ce moment alors il y a eu des gestes
il y a la CAN qui s'est réunie à Lima
c'est quoi la CAN la Cann c'est la
communaité des nations indines Colombie
Pérou
Équateur Venezuela et ils se sont réunis
pour essayer de trouver une solution
régionale mais on voit bien vous l'avez
dit euh c'est un premier pas de de Corp
donner des efforts mais c'est
insuffisant puisque le marché est
mondial est global en effet depuis
Guayaki la drogue va désormais en Asie
également vers de nouveaux marchés ouais
donc d'autres pays ont proposé leur aide
dans Amérique latine le Brésil
l'Argentine la France euh a
donné quelques quelques armes et des
conseillers et puis surtout les
États-Unis euh il y a une rencontre
entre la Générale en chef des armées du
Sud et les forces armées équatoriennes
pour essayer de coordonner un plan
d'action mais on voit que cette réponse
finalement reste encore assez mal
coordonnée la solution en effet ne peut
être qu'international et global et passe
aussi par des financements sur le long
terme pour le moment la réponse par la
militarisation suppose un énorme effort
financier de la part du gouvernement les
caisses sont vides le pays est a été
extrêmement frappé par diverses crises
notamment celle du covid et c'est donc
extrêmement difficile et là euh
aujourd'hui on a commencé à présenter à
l'assemblée nationale une un projet de
loi d'augmentation de la TVA qui devrait
passer de 12 à 15 % et l'opposition qui
était unie autour de cette handigment de
la violence par la nationale commence à
s'riter un peu commence à dire qu'elle
n'appuiera plus du tout cette politique
si elle passe par l'augmentation de la
TVA alors vous allez nous dire dans dans
un instant qui est ce ce président
équatorien mais je vous propose d'abord
de de de l'écouter le 8 janvier dernier
donc c'est après l'évasion de ses chefs
de gang il décrète l'état d'urgence
Daniel
Noboa j'ai donné des ordres clairs et
précis aux commandants de l'armée et de
la police pour qu'ils interviennent dans
le contrôle des prison je viens de
signer le décret sur l'état d'urgence
pour que les forces armées aient tout le
soutien politique et juridique dans leur
action ce que nous voyons dans les
prisons du pays est le résultat de la
décision de les affronter c'est pourquoi
le gouvernement a pris des mesures pour
prendre le contrôle des prisons perdues
ces dernières années et en réponse ces
groupes narcoterroristes tentent de nous
intimider et estiment que nous allons
céder à leurs
exigence card en quelques mots c'est qui
il vient d'O alors c'est à la fois un
homme qui se présente politiquement
comme nouveau et pourtant qui vient
d'une famille les plus riches du pays le
père Alvaro Noa a été candidat à 5in
reprises en 20ain et c'est finalement le
fils qui réalise le le le rêve familial
en portant un PR président alors il est
président par intérim c'est ça pour
quelques pour quelques mois un peu plus
d'un année présid non pas par intérim
mais pour un temps extrêmement court de
seulement 16 mois puisqu'en 2025
c'est-à-dire l'année prochaine vont se
tenir de nouvelles élections générales
présidentielle et également législative
alors comment il a pu arriver pardon de
vous interrompre mais pour à la
présidence pour 16 mois seulement ça
semble un
peuesque quoi le président précédent
guillermasso a actionné un dispositif
nouveau qui a été créé par la
Constitution de 2008 qui s'appelle la
mort croisée la muerte crousada il était
mis en accusation par l'Assemblée
nationale et euh il souhaitait je
suppose éviter ce ce cette épreuve
difficile du coup au bout de 2 ans il a
actionné la mort croisée il s'est
autoissou il a dissou l'assemblée ok ce
qui a euh permis la convocation à ces
élections premier tour en mois d'O
2è tour en décembre et voilà un jeune
président 36 ans élu pour seulement 16
mois et qui doit convaincre il qui donc
est est en campagne électorale pour une
réélection c'est ce qu'on est ce qu'on
est en train de de de comprendre et et
on a vu th no le le le l'Union nationale
là elle elle est en train de d'éclater
en quelque sorte parce qu'on est le le
compte enfin il y a il y avait une union
nationale sur l'état d'urgence sur les
moyens mis en œuvre pour lutter contre
ces ces trafiqu drogue ça s'ffrite déjà
ça sera dur à tenir le long d'un
processus électoral dont un état qui a
été déstabilisé quand même qui a eu du
mal en tout cas à trouver sa stabilité
depuis un certain nombre d'années si ce
n'est décennies ça va être très très dur
à tenir d'autant plus que les résultats
vont être très difficiles à obtenir on
sait très bien qu' il y a des questions
on l'a dit he de de financement de la de
la lutte contre la drogue il y a aussi
des questions de préparation la lutte
contre la drogue ne se mène pas avec une
armée régulière ni avec une la police la
plus classique ça suppose un temps de
préparation au tâch spécifique de la
lutte contre la drogue ça suppose des
objectifs préfis précis savoir
exactement ce qu'on fait suppose
effectivement une coordination
internationale coordination d'action qui
d'ailleurs est pas toujours désintéressé
de la part des acteurs qui peuvent
financer ses mouvements et attendre
certaines actions ou d'autres parfois
dans d'autres dans champ que le le
trafic de drogue et encore une fois la
la mise en action ensuite risque d'être
très difficile d'autant plus qu'on sait
qu'on a des institutions de sécurité qui
pour l'instant sont très largement
gangrainé par la corruption d'ailleurs
comme pas mal d'institutions en général
de comme le monde public ou privé en
Équateur alors pour prendre conscience
quand même du climat de de peur de
terreur qui règne en Équateur depuis
depuis plusieurs alors plusieurs années
on l'a compris mais particulièrement
depuis plusieurs semaines et et
l'évasion de ces deux chefs de gang
alors regardez ces ces images des hommes
armé cagoulé qui prennent en otage des
journalistes et et plus généralement des
employés
de la alors là c'est la télévision
publique qui s'appelle TC et puis on
vous propose un témoignage il est
anonyme l'image vous allez voir elle est
totalement floutée et je pense que c'est
à la hauteur de la peur ressentie par ce
salarié de de la télé
publique nous étions dans la salle de
rédaction j'ai alors vu une collègue au
visage terrifié qui disait ils vientnent
nous tuer ils sont déjà rentrer dans la
chaîne au même moment j'entends des
coups de feu beaucoup de bruit je quitte
alors l'endroit où se trouvait la
rédactrice en chef j'attrape mon
téléphone portable et je me mets à
courir comme un fou vers un endroit sûr
à la suite de cette prise d'otage il y a
un procureur qui est nommé il s'appelle
César Suarez enfin il s'appelait
puisqu'il sera assassiné le 17 janvier
écoutez suite à l'assassinat de notre
collègue César Suarez procureur de
l'unité nationale spécialisé dans les
enquêtes sur la criminalité
transnationale organisée à Guayas je
vais être
catégorique les groupes criminels
organisés les criminels et les
terroristes ne stopperont pas notre
engagement envers la société
équatorienne nous continuerons avec plus
de force
encore César repose en paix ton héritage
nous accompagnera dans la lutte voilà la
procureur générale de l'équateur c'est
en quelque sorte le premier magistrat du
du pays ce que vous me disiez à
l'instant Christophe Ventura je reste
avec vous thier Noël parce que quand on
regarde les images de la prise d'otage
et cetera on sait qui est derrière
est-ce que ces cartel enfin où ces gangs
se sentent si puissant qu'il
revendiquent quasiment le le la prise
d'otage oui c'est une démonstration de
force on sait jamais qui exactement le
fait on sait que ces organisations c'est
gang hein c'est plus des gangs que des
des cartels proprement dit c'est ces
gangs sont son en contrôle sont en
conflit entre eux tous revendiquent de
toute façon et profitent du fait de ce
mescao là euh paradoxalement c'est pas
franchement du goût de leur leur
fournisseur de drogue qui eux en général
préfèrent que les choses soient les plus
discrètes et les plus efficac possible
mais il peut y avoir des moments comme
cuxla de malheureusement des
démonstration de force aussi grossier
soit-il et est-ce qu'il y a des signes
distinctifs je me souviens des des Maras
cétait des tatouages est-ce qu'il y a
des des on cherchait sur les vidéos des
gestes avec les mains est-ce queil y a
des signes distinctifs de de ces
différents gangs à votre connaissance ça
fait partie he effectivement ça fait
partie de la culture narco et en
particulier importé par des depuis le
Salvador par ces fameuses fuse marace
c'est des groupe qu'on connaît bien
visage tatoué c'est distinctif il y en a
mais c'est c'est moins discret ces
derniers temps on a quand même vu alias
fito le donc le le grand fugitif en ce
moment revendiquer des signes
traditionnels du de l'équateur drapeau
équatorien drapeau régional de la région
de Manabi chapeau traditionnel aussi
c'est ve dire se poser un peu comme a pu
faire un Escobar à une époque se pososer
en figure de de Rebell du pays là là on
on parle d'un assassinat assassinat d'un
procureur vous l'avez évoqué mais très
rapidement tout à l'heure Emmanuel
Cardet il y a aussi donc eu un un
candidat à la présidentielle qui a été
tué c'est ça là aussi c'était un signe
de de la dérive du pays évidemment oui
oui oui alors céit un candidat qui avait
axé son programme sur la lutte contre la
corruption et il parlait lui de
narcoétat et euh il avait un programme
qui visait à remettre à plat les
institutions exigerit la transparence et
il dénonçait plusieurs hommes
politiques non seulement des
fonctionnaires mais aussi tout un
système politique qui aurait été
gangrainé euh par le narcotrafic et en
effet il a été assassiné à quelques
jours du premier tour ça a été un
véritable choc une sidération pour la
population parce qu'elle s'était
toujours définie comme différente de ses
pays voisins du Mexique également comme
un pays bon avec ses difficultés mais
tranquille et pacifique on trouvait
quand même des solutions on va dire euh
relativement négocié et et ça a été
véritablement un choc où là ils ont
compris que cette violence qu'il
croyaaiit euh peut-être se limiter à
quelques zones du pays où les prisons
étaient véritablement euh absolument
partout oui ça a été un électrochoc une
sorte de prise de conscience euh le
président équatorien Daniel Noboa il a
donc choisi euh la méthode forte état
d'urgence mobilisation de l'armée face à
la violence de ces cartels de la drogue
et on va voir qu'il s'inspire d'un pays
voisin avec Jonathan du priez tout de
suite Jonathan qui nous rejoint sur le
plateau de de sens public on parle du
Salvador bonsoir Jonathan donnez-nous
des détails alors oui effectivement
beaucoup voi la stratégie du du
président équatorien une copie carbone
de la méthode bouqué du nom de l'actuel
président du Salvador naïib boukeleé
vous allez voir aussi une carte où se
trouve le Salvador parce que je suis pas
sûr que tout le monde le sache alors
naïib bouel lui il a 42 ans il est au
manette de ce petit pays d'Amérique
latine de 6000 million et demi
d'habitants et donc il est à la tête de
ce pays depuis 2019 et se tarque d'avoir
fait de cet état le plus sûr de
l'Amérique latine avec l'armée naï bouel
a mené une guerre féroce au gang de
narcotrafiquants qui gangrainent le
Salvador considéré il y a moins de 10
ans comme la capitale mondiale du crime
avec une vingtaine d'assassinats par
jour ce qui est énorme en proportion de
sa population naï bouel devenu
extrêmement populaire avec tous ces tous
ces faits d'armes contre les narcos on a
fait un argument politique alors qu'il
est en pleine campagne électorale
écoutez-le ce 4 février nous devrons
protéger les acquis en matière de
sécurité actuellement mon parti dispose
d'une majorité qualifiée mais avec un
seul député en moins nous perdrions
cette majorité mettrions en péril la
guerre contre les
gangs et voilà Thomas et la victoire lui
est promise dans 3 jours les instituts
de sondage le donneent à 70 80 %
effectivement mais cette méthode forte
donc brandie par le préant bouquelé elle
n'est pas sans dérive elle n'est pas
sans dérive non parce que on est en
droit maintenant de se de se demander si
cette guerre des gang finalement fait
pas basculer le le Salvador dans dans un
régime littéralement autoritaire et
c'est ce que pensent de nombreux
observateurs depuis que qu'il a
déclenché l'état d'urgence dont vous
parliez aussi pour le cas équatorien
c'est un état d'urgence au Salvador
ultra répressif hein qui a été mis en
place en mars 2022 après un weekend où
il y a eu 87 assassinats recensés et
donc il y a l'armée qui est déployée
dans les à ce momentl des villes
entières sont encerclé et les gangs sont
extirpés des rues avec la manière la
plus forte possible ça fait que 70000
personnes sont jetées en prison le plus
grand centre carcéral d'Amérique latine
est même créé à cette occasion avec
40000 place dedans voilà donc vous voyez
certaines images qui sont
impressionnantes et aujourd'hui ça fait
que 1,6 % de la population du Salvador
est sous les verrous c'est un chiffre
assez vertigéneux c'est c'est le plus le
chiffre le plus élevé au monde et donc
s'accompagne de de toutes C ces images
de nombreux cas recensés de torture
d'arrestation arbitraires qui serait
devenu légion le tout sans presque aucun
contrôle sur ces dérives comme le point
de certaines ONG
écoutez ce qu'a fait bouel serait
impossible dans une démocratie parce
qu'il n'existe absolument aucun contrôle
sur son action ni des institutions ni de
la société civile ni des médias parce
qu'il a créé un espace où il est
impossible de s'opposer à de le
critiquer ou même de le question en tout
cas bouel à l'opinion pour lui hein le
modèle semble plaire et on parle même
donc ce modèle fait des émules on parle
même de bouquellisation de ces
démocraties d'Amérique latine et
centrale mais il y a aussi un un autre
aspect c'est que certaines de ces
démocraties ont fait machine arrière
celle qui avait basculé dans le Tour
répressif la Colombie le Mexique contre
les narcos semble un peu faire machine
arrière et revenir vers des politiques
plus sociales d'accompagnement de la
jeunesse notamment pour éviter violence
prennent toute la société merci beaucoup
Jonathan al c'est vraiment une partie de
notre débat que je trouve euh
particulièrement passionnante la
première elle était aussi mais c'est
c'est quel moyen une démocratie peut
mettre en œuvre quand elle est à ce
point gangrainé par des par des
narcotrafiquants moi je vais vous donner
ma ma première action je vois des
narcotrafiquants voilà sortir en en
caleçon d'un d'un d'un d'un bus et être
aligné dans une salle gigantesque je
vais pas pleurer sur eux mais est-ce
est-ce que c'est la forcément la bonne
solution bah l'histoire montre que ce
n'est pas la bonne solution pourquoi bah
parce qu'en fait le résultat c'est un
peu ce que je disais tout à l'heure le
résultat n'est pas là il y a des
résultats temporaires il a des résultats
à un moment donné qui peuvent suivre qui
peuvent déjà être apprécié par les
populations dans un contexte est ce
qu'on voit au Salvador on veut on veut
de la sécurité on veut pouvoir sortir de
ces chix de chez soi tranquillement
enfin voilà et et c'est possible en
mettant en prison ceux qui vous
terrorisent voilà mais ça l'histoire
montre que ça dure un temps puis après
il y a une autre PHAs ouais où vous
commencez à voir un peu les cadavres
dans le placard si j'ose dire
c'est-à-dire ce que votre chroniqueur a
expliqué c'est-à-dire des dérives lentes
qui vont après vers la mise en place
d'escadron de la mort par exemple qui
vont après vers des justicce des
meurtres et des des persécutions
extrajudiciaire même le gouvernement de
bouquelé commence à admettre que
peut-être sur les 70000 personnes qui
ont été arrêté le gouvernement parle de
6000 qui n'auraiit rien à faire en
prison bon tout ça va remonter un petit
peu à la surface et puis surtout le
problème si vous pouvez détruire la Mara
savata ou le Bario qui sont les deux
principaux gangs dont on parle dans le
reportage mais tant que les causes qui
produisent tout cela perdurent bah il y
aura des
remplaants c'est comme on coupe une
tête à chaque fois dans le le passage de
entre le coupage de tête et puis l'dre
ce qui se passe c'est que le narco et la
criminalité est plus sophistiquée elle
se renforce c'est c'est la la relation
du glve et du
et donc tout ça se réorganise c'est
moléculaire il y a des cellules qui se
reconstituent des nouveaux chefs qui
apparaissent et cetera parce que d'un
côté il y a quand même toujours on tombe
sur ce problème de la consommation
exponentielle qui augmente deuxièmement
il y a démocratie et démocratie parce
que des démocraties centreaméricaines ou
latinaméricaines qui sont des
démocraties de pays qui vivent avec à
peu près un tiers de pauvreté dans
chaque pays qui vivent avec des
inégalités social habissal où il y a
zéro opportunités pour la jeunesse pour
les parents aussi où il y a pas d' au
services sociaux pas d'accès aux
services public bah vous créez une
situation vous allez B être une
démocratie bah dans les fait la société
elle est insoutenable pour les gens il
faut comprendre ça choque peut-être les
gens mais que le narco ou la mafia ou
les organisations criminelles ce sont
des organisations qui en quelque sorte
s'installe là où l'État défilles là où
l'État n'existe pas joue aussi un rôle
social joue un rôle social et c'est pour
ça que ça fonctionne parce que c'est
aussi des organisations où il y a de la
solidarité c'est aussi des organisations
il y a des opportunités c'est des
organisations qui vous
in bien sûr que so pr mourir assz jeunes
une balle dans la tête ou finir en
prison mais quand vous êtes dans des
sociétés où c'est ça bah c'est comme ça
que ça se passe on est dans quelle phase
là je reviens en Équateur Emmanuel
Sinard on est dans la dans dans le tout
début de la phase de répressive avec
peut-être pour les habitants quand même
oui ce soulagement est-ce que c'est ça
ce qui se passe en ce moment oui oui
c'est on a le sentiment d'un soulagement
il y a eu déjà eu quelques effets où il
y aurait une diminution de la moitié des
crimes et lorsque on voit certaines
scènes comme des des des des gens hein
des passants qui viennent embrasser
certains policiers qui offrent à boire
qui offre des fruits au militaire qui
patrouillent on voit bien que
euh il y a une attente de restauration
de l'autorité de l'État c'est pas
simplement l'ordre c'est de l'autorité
de l'État mais ça ça peut fonctionner
peut-être un mois 2 mois ensuite de
toute façon ces narcos vont euh se
déplacer ne serait-ce qu'aller dans les
régions voisines le Pérou et la Colombie
ont décidé de fermer leur frontières
sagement en se disant qu'au moins cela
ne passerait pas chez eux mais c'est
reportter le problème vers d'autres
espaces et puis en effet les causes
profondes sont toujours là alors Daniel
Noboa avait été élu aussi parce qu'il
proposait un programme
centriste où il promettait un meilleur
accès justement au service public
notamment à l'éducation et à
l'université et il s semblait parler
particulièrement en raison de son âge
d'une part et de son style aussi euh
auprès d'un jeune électorat qui souvent
vter pour la première fois il a beaucoup
communiqué également sur les réseaux
sociaux sa femme est une tiktokeuse une
influenceuse assez connu donc il avait
des codes pour convaincre qu'il pouvait
représenter une alternative en tout cas
mais pour le moment en effet le le le le
choix de la militarisation consiste à
rendre une situation devenu
insoutenable acceptable ou moins
soutenable sur le court terme oui
j'avais une question c'est que tout à
l'heure Jonathan disait que par exemple
la Colombie avait fait le choix
complètement inverse était revenu en
arrière par exemple sur ses approches de
militarisation est-ce que l'approche
inverse a montré fait plus de preuves ou
al on peut en parler effectivement de la
de la Colombie peut-être votre avis
là-dessus Tiry Noël parce que je je en
préparant l'émission je disais que
l'équateur c'était un peu la Colombie
des années peut-être 90 est-ce que ils
en sont où les Colombiens aujourd'hui
d'abord ils ont après exporté la
violence euh on a le cas de l'équateur
on a le cas du Venezuela aussi qui qui
pass délocalise la violence chez les
voisins et notamment les les routes de
transit hein donc on transforme ces
zones ces pays en zone de transit où ont
lieu les disputes euh et il y a
évidemment des politiques qui ont été
faites en Colombie de pacification
parfois au niveau national parfois au
niveau local il y a eu un travail
extraordinaire qui a une époque a été
fait la ville de M Dine qui était le la
Capitale du Crime pendant très longtemps
la fameuse ville de Pablo escobard et il
y a un travail social bah d'accès au
servic public à des choses aussi simple
que l'eau et l'électricité le gaz et
cetera et après il faut le dire c'est
souvent d'ailleurs un N dit il y a un
choix qui a été fait par le narcotrafic
colombien de faire profil bas on arrête
après toutes ces années de de faire au
contraire à la Escobar dans la
provocation on fait le profil bas c'est
ce qu'on appelle cette génération
souvent la génération des Invisibles euh
c'est un téléphone
trunur et on limite trafic on ESS
d'adopter un niveau de classe moyenne
supérieure mais pas excessif non plus
pour êre pas mat tu vu et le fait il
faut bien dire que ça marche très bien
alors même qu'il y a quand même on le
sait une violence souterraine en
Colombie qui reste assez importante mais
est-ce que vous avez en partie répondu à
à la question mais je je je précise
est-ce qu'il y a une démocratie
confrontée comme ça à des à des
trafiquant ultra puissant qui qui a
réussi à s'en débarrasser sans la sans
passer par la violence vous voyez ce que
je veux dire non a priori la la Colombie
l'a fait la question est de savoir
est-ce que c'est durable c'est à quel
point c'est durable on sait que ce sont
des cycles ce sont des cycles on est
déjà dans ce qu'on appelle les les
narcos 3è version génération 3 on verra
le reste ça se déplace comme comme le de
crisov ça se déplace on peut à des
moments décapiter des organisations
elles vont se mettre ell migr ailleurs
d'autres pays donc la question sair
est-ce que ça tient la phase de violence
elle y est quand même on parle au
passage pour le Salvador on parle
beaucoup de de Na bouel il y a une phase
qui a précédé don on parle très peu qui
a été d'une extrême violence où le où
l'État salvadorien sétait engagé dans
une guerre contre les marac ou alors là
on parlait de milliers de morts dans les
rues qui avait préparé un bouquelet qui
lui emprisonne essentiellement alors
avec un dénis des droits vous avez très
bien exposé mais effectivement ça il y a
eu d'abord une phase de de violence
extrême c'est courant
il y a une perte de contrôle
effectivement la reconquête de l'État
passe aussi par ça même si c'est c'est
évidemment pas la solution à tout et
est-ce qu'elle est durable ou
certainement pas alors l'une des
solutions en tout cas une des décisions
prises par le président équatorien
Daniel Noboa ça a été l'expulsion des
délinquants étrangers
écoutez sur les quelques 3000 personnes
privées de liberté actuellement
étrangère celles qui ont une peine de 5
ans ou plus vont être expulsé du pays ce
qui représente environ 1500 personnes
Christophe Ventura ils peuvent revenir
si la frontière est aussi poreuse ou
alors c'est une façon d'appliquer ce que
les autres ont fait c'est on on refile
j'allais dire la patate chaude pardon de
la trivialité mais à à d'autres pays ben
oui c'est ça que ça veut dire il y a des
expériences documentées là-dessus depuis
tout le monde je fais le lien
excusez-moi encore avec le Salvador mais
c'est bien un des drames du Salvador
c'est qu'on avait on avait expulsé des
États-Unis euh les les délinquants
Salvadoriens qui qui avaient monté leur
gang à Los Angeles et cetera ils sont
revenus au Salvador ça s'est pas arrêté
qu'est-ce qui va se passer ben il va se
passer qu'ils vont reprendre leurs
affaires là où ils seront parce que les
réseaux sont établis parce qu'on
travaille avec des des diaspora avec des
prisons et et et les gens ou mais enfin
si je suis équatoorien je me dis au
moins ils sont plus chez moi oui mais ça
c'est euh si vous voulez c'est ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire que
ça c'est une perception qui dure un
temps mais ça ne change pas le problème
ça le déplace ça leur ça ça complique la
vie des narcos un moment donné ça
modifie les hiérarchie entre eux oui
mais ça ne change pas euh que le la la
la l'activité va continuer et quand vous
P les gens c'est une mesure sécuritaire
qui rassure c'est vrai que ça rassure
mais ça va pas modifier la structure du
problème est-ce que vous diriez que
c'est une
malédiction sud-américaine dont on est
en train de parler puisque moi ce que
j'entends là en vous écoutant c'est que
finalement elle se déplace d'un pays à
l'autre en Amérique du Sud en Amérique
centrale ça supposerait qu'il y a une
sorte de fatalité de la violence en
Amérique latine non enfin moi en tout
cas je ne le pense pas en revanche en
effet il y a eu des moments si on se
place dans un temps plus long
d'affaibliss de l'autorité de l'État et
quand je dis de l'autorité de l'État
c'est aussi symboliquement d'ailleurs
ces militaires qui reprenaient certaines
prisons qui étaient aux mains des
narcotrafiquants en Équateur la première
chose qu'il faisait dans la cour c'était
monter le drapeau national comme si le
pays la nation récupérer des territoires
qui auraient été perdus au profit des
narcotrafiquants et il y a eu
différentes phases et notamment un
moment clé ça a été cette décennie qu'on
appelle perdue des années 80 90 avec une
une une très
forte politique d'ajustement dit
structurel dont vous avez parlé et qui a
eu pour effet véritablement affaiblir de
façon progressive sur le long terme
l'État et on le voit dans le choix
peut-être du dollar hein l'équateur a
pour monnaie le dollar a renoncé donc au
soucré qui était sa monnaie historique
euh et certains y ont vu justement la
manifestation d'un retrait du National
euh pour de très bonnes raisons
peut-être financière ou économique la
question n'est pas là mais on a le
sentiment en tout cas que l'autorité
publique est affaiiblie et pénétré
notamment par les narcotrafiquants le le
la grande opération menée par la
procureur générale qu'on a vu sur votre
écan Diana Salah sage qui s'appelle
métastase tout est déjà dans le nom de
l'opération a été mené avec 900
fonctionnaires en même temps dans le
pays dans le plus grand secret parce
qu'elle craignait les fuites pendant un
an elle a été préparée on a vu
l'arrestation de la tête même de la
police en charge de la lutte contre la
corruption et du numéro 2 du ministère
de la
Justice merci beaucoup c'était
passionnant merci d'avoir participé à ce
débat je vais rappeler le le titre de
les titres de vos livres Christophe
Ventura
désoccidentalisation repenser l'ordre du
monde on est aux éditions Agon et thry
Noël la guerre des cartels aux éditions
vendémièr merci encore je vous souhaite
une bonne fin de soirée sur public sénna
on se retrouve lundi merci Tam c'est
toujours un plaisir de vous avoir sur ce
sur ce plateau notez que demain l'invité
de la matinale ce sera le politologue
Bruno tertray 8h du matin face à Oriane
monsini belle
[Musique]
soirée